let's do a round of applause for you
guys your name your age and a fun fact
I'm
Henry
um
um fun facts about me
um I love planes
I love anything that flies basically
so
okay and then why don't we go around in
the back for me yeah I'm Dre I'm 35 I
was 23 I did a for Monty
[Laughter]
35 in two days relationship state is a
single fun fact about me when I was a
kid about eight or nine that's for me
did it taste good
horrible how do they convince you
say it's ice cream he was like trying to
be nice I'm like no I want to try it but
at least I said all right cool older
brother you believe it that's my fun
fact my name is Becca I'm 32 and fun
fact about me I just I'm in Britain
sometimes yeah wait just because it's
very who is to blame for pregnancy
men or women or does it take two to
tango so I want to go around everyone
give your take on that question I feel
like it takes two to tango okay yeah
um what who's to blame men or women yeah
um this might be a um
what do they call it a
controversial yeah
I say women women why because men don't
know that men are probably just there
for the both obviously both they're like
she's hot in there
they just know so yeah and it's more
also you know if you do get pregnant
who who who's more responsible who's
more responsible for it who's the one
that can have that final decision to the
women
okay
for sure okay yeah
because I think sex is not to self
um it's more costly to women than men
I think
men have a part to play in it as well
because you know you know what you're
about to do not to believe her
um and I think you need to take
responsibility for the actions
whether if I if the person if the guy
wanted it or not
um
yeah she would be to blame if you want
to say that
yeah 50 50. both
to blame so why do women call themselves
the creators of life when the pregnancy
is wanted oh and the example they use it
anyone I don't think they should use
that term he got me knocked up you got
yourself knocked up like you literally
went into it knew that no matter what
contraception you're taking it's never
do everything right and she can still
steal the condom very wealthy men that's
actually very common for like people in
certain positions most men you're right
it's rare it's not for all men but like
super wealthy man that's very common
they were misled to think she wasn't
taking the pill or something similar I
thought the thing expires in like 10
years yeah I just know every year but to
really learn like most of us I feel like
it's it takes two to tango to get
pregnant and it's I don't know why it's
more women's fault yeah like you said uh
sorry
right
um
we all know people who like there's
something there's been some guys that
are quite great girl pregnant and he
wants the baby she doesn't want it she
makes the last decision who's blame to
their pregnant what I'm saying is I'm
just trying to get women pregnant if you
strap up who has the final say without
that pregnancy
we're not saying who has the final seat
to give the beef so beef yeah it's a
woman but you're pregnant it's too too
bad but she can change that situation
but wouldn't you say the woman has more
power in general yeah because because
the woman has 41 forms of birth control
you can require the men that they wear
condoms so like what I'm saying is it's
more on the woman because we have more
power I would say yeah it's it's I would
blame the woman because you know you
know when you're ovulating exactly yeah
and he does it and so that's just so
much more power that we have where he
could wear a condom and it breaks just
think men are responsibility so right
okay quick question then if if a girl
got pregnant off a one night both well
he's supposed to have called her to say
yo is it your time
but it's a bit of a girl's fault too I'm
gonna give him 100 he will be half full
because she doesn't um self give a give
a [ __ ] about to blame them not even 10
blame me it's your fault no it's both
people no
once once the semen leaves a guy he has
no control do you know what I mean so he
has no control yeah yeah it's different
from Fault like yeah once it leaves you
you'll have no control
we pick who has sex yeah
all right you're telling me you should
say oh no that's like like I mean I just
feel like men are programmed to do that
I would say women should take more
precaution because it will change their
life way more if you're having a child
but yeah I can I can understand
it's like ten versus one exactly
yeah if I'm if I play for the NFL or
something then I I know it'll probably
hurt me let me ask you be careful it's a
man if you had a son and he got natural
to him so how much would you blame him
like
or for having sex forgetting someone
pregnant and being oh what do you mean
okay he could have had condenser and he
broke
[Laughter]
shooting up in random chicks yeah like
that's not wise but the point is we have
so much more power than the men that
like if I had to blame someone I'm
blaming the woman I don't think it's 50
50. even I don't even think it's close
to 50 50. we can require they wear
condoms or not and it's like we have all
of these precautions where the men have
won I feel like we just start looking
who to blame who to blame because then I
could say oh my parents never told me
anything I didn't know much it's just my
nature and I've done it um yeah but
there's Google like come on no I would
say I didn't know many things on my
phone no one knew so
you know they don't talk nowadays they
very push this free movement right and
no one said oh save yourself like my
parents I had no talk about
relationships so
I forgot what you have sex same with the
guy if if he has unprotected he can't
say oh some girl got pregnant I feel
like it's 50 you got some girl pregnant
but I'm gonna tell him that he's
irresponsible obviously no he's
irresponsible for obviously shooting up
the club but what yes that's true I
agree you know why do you think there
hasn't been male birth control
it's not medically like impossible or do
you think if they wanted to find it they
could have I I have a hard time
believing that they're creating
artificial wounds but they couldn't feel
I asked you guys the question
I could tell you my opinion after but
why don't you guys I'm assuming it might
be harder to
but I'm sure right sorry sorry I'm just
saying assuming it might be harder as
it's a lot of a lot of sperm swimming
around in there stop all our soldiers
running in it might be a bit more tricky
it could be also that I don't know
um if you were to give main
contraceptions would just be you know um
what do you think what do you think
Society how do you think society would
change if we gave and would take over
they would have all the power then
I agree
I feel like
yeah
that you probably see less of you know
um on plant babies because we're more
logical I think so no I haven't had um
surround because men will actually be a
lot more responsible because they know
yeah the effects of their either their
promiscuity or I mean so there would be
um a lot more careful
about probably who they sleep with or
they'll make sure they actually take the
contraceptives or whatever it is like a
reverse role yeah how it is now yeah
so I think there'll be less single
parents around yeah I agree and probably
less children because a lot of men
probably don't want to have children
until later on in life so there'd be
less children and
the society will be probably like Japan
where there are one child
what did you when you said that men are
irresponsible what did you mean by it
like if it depends with where you are
um and but I think
and that if you do give this power to
men they would be so much more
responsible and more logical really I
think they'd be much more responsible
with it especially with the way the laws
are now
um I mean like you don't want to you
don't want to knock up the wrong girl
you're gonna be paying for it for 20
years maybe they would be more
responsible because more times than men
don't want the child so they probably
would be more responsible about it
um
probably well in regards to taking the
contraception but if they're not
responsible without it yeah then what
would make them more responsible with it
because I feel like men just lean on the
fact that oh I just need I just have one
thing to do and that is only my response
yeah but then nothing else silly to the
consequence of that yeah exactly no
they're not for like now it's just like
the responsibility is off me yeah it's
like I can do whatever I want and you
know if as long as I have protection
then that's my duty that's my like
everything else is not me right now so
if you were to reverse the roles they
would have to think more oh well I need
to do this I need to do this they would
have to be more responsible I wouldn't
say that men would think that it's not
me but say for example you are taken
contraception we ain't taking condoms
and let's say for example we made a
woman pregnant we have no power anyway
so I wouldn't say automatically men are
like okay cool there's nothing more I I
say I'm done it's more like okay this is
all I can do
yeah because for example it's limited if
we could equally make a decision whether
this child can be born or not I'm pretty
sure men would give more input but how
many times have you heard men trying to
give an opinion and a woman's like nope
what I say is what it is yeah that's
true some say and also another point I
was going to add is
it's a lot of the times due to the
emotional attachment of the baby grain
inside you sometimes your decisions may
not be for the best because as men we
don't go through that our brains are
always going to think more logically
because we don't have that attachment so
we might I might be like for example my
lifestyle right now isn't ready for a
child when you're allow powerful right
now it doesn't make sense to me getting
this baby because I'm gonna I know I'm
gonna feel after that I'm thinking if we
bring this into the world
our financial situation or our living
situation is not beneficial for this
child so it's better that we don't have
this child but that's once you've
already conceived how is my life going
to change
do you guys think what she's saying is
true just by enlarge the guys in the
room no I I think most men do think
about the consequences
it's
unfortunate that you know sometimes
babies are born
um
but I know speaking for myself I I I
think about all the consequences of all
the actions that I do before I get into
anything you know
um I'm I try and take responsibility for
the actions that I take and I try and
always preempt what might happen if I
engage in a particular act no matter
what it is so
but I don't know I'm just looking from a
perspective of like let's say night club
State I don't think many guys drink and
think like oh I might get pregnant they
just see a hot ass and they go for it
but then also do that too also to add to
that so if a woman is just as
irresponsible as a man is for example
let's say
I'm gonna have sex with someone for
example if this woman doesn't really
care at all about contraception anything
then it's like okay if you don't care
more times I'm not gonna care but you
should be very serious about the
protection that's going to make me
serious but you should put your own life
in your hands knowing some strangers to
your man because now you're you're in
your life or your you know how your life
is gonna go to some stranger if you're
easy I'm easy if you're serious then I'm
more protected that's you shouldn't do
that well then I think the decisions we
make are based on get pregnant what
happens you're still beautiful I can
still moved to Miami for a new job and
you know you see a child once a week
once a month once a year or something
but you can't so is that okay
I'm just saying that that's the risk for
them is way less you know I think the
risk is more for men more yeah having a
kid with the wrong girl it can ruin your
life you could be on child support for
18 years people commit suicide over not
still part to blame
um I mean I I don't think it's why I
have a friend that we know personally
and
he was with his um wife at the time but
you today
disagreements for example he is fighting
fighting hard to get some form of
custody over their child
but because she is the female she gets
more priority and he's fighting fighting
fighting to the point where he told me
how stressed he is sleepless nights
wanting to see his children but she's
just like no and then and they're not
really giving him the time of day
do you not think in that situation I've
seen a lot of women know the man very
well they know how to push the buttons
and the man just doesn't know how to
control that woman like sometimes if you
just give a woman silence she'll come to
you and say oh can you see the child or
something like that you know so I feel
like those men did not maybe as equipped
or or mentally they're just going the
wrong route you know where the woman has
all the power and you just keep betting
her or you know but then while you have
to beg to see his child no if he stops
she will come after USA
can you guarantee that there's not every
woman may think like some women need to
try some women are just spiteful I think
but it's like that shouldn't be legal
yeah yeah it's very wrong because if the
other way around I'm pretty sure the
same energy that's being pulled towards
him wouldn't be full I think it takes a
strong man to control a woman and not
have that baby drama but there's a way
you can do it
what do you what do you guys think yeah
yeah there's a plan you can do it yeah I
mean like do you think it's easy to
control baby mamas
yeah but there's a way but it's
difficult but it's possible it depends
on your situation yeah it is possible
yeah
what do you guys think yeah no the issue
I have here is the whole point of it's
gonna be a strong man to control a woman
but then the same way you still be
criticizing the man if you're not
feeling his role as a father so it's
like I have a way as a man is like why
does every man have to be strong to be
able to have it's hard to be a man to
their child so I'm saying it can be a
hard life for a man I feel like right
from the start of the problems if she
starts giving problems referring to the
baby mama don't like seeing baby mama
the mother of your child and stuff yeah
and a lot of you got to give the
impression that you're ready to walk
away and it's a lot of times if you give
that impression that you're ready to
work and mean it yeah trust me things
gonna go your way when she knows you're
staying and you're gonna be then Chase
Chase is gonna make it harder that's my
I think I have experience for my
childhood that's drama and then if I do
walk away thinking that it might work
you can come back you ain't doing right
by your child it doesn't matter your
child will know when you grow up you can
tell well I know there's damage but you
know know
you can walk away for a year I swear
she's gonna come back and say can you
see your child she might she might not
this is all assumptions right now you
said that you know there might be damage
to the child but what about you you've
missed a year of your child's life like
yeah maybe the child in the future won't
remember they might but in the first
four years the first four years of life
that's when the most development happens
exactly like I I know um a decent amount
about adoption and like this relates to
us but yeah because my parents adopted
three teenagers but a lot of times like
even if you adopt a four or
five-year-old and they don't remember
like before they're they're so
psychologically damaged from like going
from different caretakers that like I
have a friend um that I knew through
church and like she had
um a brother that was just like so
damaged from the first four years of his
life being and so in being with
inconsistent caretakers that had damaged
him for life and he was always like the
problem kid in the family I mean it is
unfair
um the the power between women and men
when there's you know they're not
together and there's a child is just a
lot of disadvantages it's very unfair
um especially even less no matter how
much you end there should be like a
cut-off point I feel like it should be
50 50 custody like off the bat like I
don't know why women are like even if
the man doesn't want 50 50 the child
would have to live with the Fonda 50.
well I mean if he doesn't want to be in
the life I guess not no he wants let's
say but he doesn't want the child's
thing like four days he wants like one
day I think off the back it's just I
think off the bat they should start with
50 50 custody and they can work it out
between them right like the government
should say you both have to yeah like
50. that makes sense yeah because I
don't know why women are just assumed to
be better parents when they're more
likely to abuse a child they're more
violent towards their children
yeah what have you seen
um
so
you can go to supermarkets you can hear
them I'm shot at the child
um I had
um I had a couple on these I would like
that and it's like I've even got some
friends that were like that and I know a
couple of times I've been like
why are you shining like that so much
sometimes obviously it's not as much
prevalent as it is now back in the day
it was a lot of beating as well but the
way I grew up all my friends me the dad
is the one you know shouting or beating
or you know the mom is not the one but
that's that's with the first percentage
in comparison but could it could it be
that it's because the moms are around
the kids more yes because you know when
you are around a child or more they
frustrate you more yeah like if you're
just coming like if you're even not in
the picture or uh if you are but like
you work a long hours and you only see
your children for like a little short
time if the mom is with them like pretty
much 24 7 they're gonna drive her crazy
I think I'm gonna disagree on that one I
think women are just more emotional yeah
true yes like like you know women are
more likely to wage war
to wage war
like percentage-wide like I know more
men have because more men have been in
power but women are actually more likely
to do it when they're in power what's
wage war like Star War oh go to war
like go to find like yeah just I think
like I just think we get pissed off I've
seen a lot of women trying to fight men
thinking what are you doing so yeah
because even in my household I love you
I lived with both parents and
if I compare the two my mom did way more
shy than what I did like he knew ways to
con not say control us but to keep us
obedient
that did beaten
as in the early early stages yes but
even then
he didn't really need to be as much we
weren't that bad as children but at the
same time it was like if he needed to
raise his voice it was situational
where my mom was shot constant that was
like
my mum used to hit me with a spoon
don't get me wrong for like uh single
mothers it's not it's not easy bringing
up a child or kids on your own it's
tough you know I I taught them for what
they do but when you start getting angry
and you know you're screaming at your
kid and there's veins coming down your
neck you know that's you just um that's
just way too much too much anger for a
child that doesn't understand what you
do the only thing they can get from
there is trauma but there's you know in
all the situations ninety percent of
women are look at the parents to the
child there's only 10 of full-time
single dance that look after the child
as the main parent just ten percent so I
feel like that doesn't government
prioritizing women yeah yeah it could be
but I feel like men don't know how it is
like to have a child almost 24 7. that's
because
single appearance single fathers raise
better children exactly than single
mothers when they have been given the
chance they've done a better job yeah I
just think women like we get frustrated
like when there's a problem yeah we just
get frustrated and like cry or get mad
yeah I do it too like like even even and
I kind of noticed the differences in
like the genders doing like solving
problems because even with like my
business like I'll be doing stuff and
I'll just be like get mad at something
and my brothers will be like okay why
don't you try this this this this like
they're just more logical do you think a
man would do a better job raising a girl
Than a Woman
yeah
yeah right what about the feminine side
um would she be more masculine then
probably
um I would say like she's probably she'd
probably be a tomboy
it might be hard to find a man my mom
was raised by my granddad so my mum was
had four siblings she's the youngest my
grand my mom my nan ran off different
life then my granddad raised worked has
his own business and raised four kids my
mum it was a single mom
I'm not
blowing it while I'm blowing a trumpet
because she's the best mum raised my
brother me and my sister strong woman
was the breadwinner was everything The
Decorator everything well she's shouting
a lot all the time but she did it
because we were bad kids
she's like she was a young mum she had
my brother about 15 me at 17.
but that she got I feel like she got
that strongness from my Grandad because
he was a very strict
working man did everything he played
both roles so I just think it
it differs whereas she was raised by a
man I was raised by a woman so I feel
like I've got both why uh I actually
like this idea that like men raised
children better I would believe that
because they're more logic why more men
is it because of the government because
I feel like a lot of men wouldn't want
100 custody of the child oh no they will
um they want their freedom too no no I
think most men want to be in their kids
lives um I can't remember what the stat
is off the top of my head but one of the
most likely times that a guy is going to
commit suicide is when it's like
post-divorce because oftentimes she'll
take yeah the divorce yeah what about
men who not like in marriage-wise yeah
but let's say men who who been in a
relation there's no marriage they just
had a child with someone who they
actually 100 because because I feel like
they're very happy with 50 or less
um are you talking about men when
there's no marriage it's just with a
woman
I don't I don't know but like in my
experience most men want to be with
their children even even if it's in a
shitty situation for the most 100 unless
they're like one of those guys that are
just you know shooting up and everybody
but that's not the majority well I don't
think most men are going to want 100
because if you're in if you're alive and
in the child's life why would you 100
you'd rather do 50 50. because at the
end of the day even the stats say that
being a better fathers there's a certain
element to a child that a man can't give
that's what a woman needs to be around
so being 100 to your child is not as
fully beneficial as it would be having
both so Jeffy me for example as a man
even though I may want 50 I'm not going
to 100 because there's certain errors I
can't give you I can't tell you what
it's like to be a woman in this world do
nothing like a lot of men are happy to
see the child twice a week and they
don't want 50 50. yeah that's probably
because they have to rather than because
I've seen guys and they they they're
happy with their like yeah two days a
week every other week yeah it's not like
it's banned everything one business a
month they're happy they're happy to you
know live their life and but then was
that yeah is that a father that was
actually heavily invested in that woman
before they had a child no if that was a
if that was an unplanned pregnancy yeah
there I I think both of them were
unplanned yes yes heavily invested and
I'm pretty sure two days might not be
enough
in his mind but you might have to sell
for it no I I know someone then asking
for someone or I know two other people
all right fair enough
but I'm just saying I personally do know
of people and me myself also I was
raised like that every other weekend so
there's people out here that just they
just don't want more responsibility with
their children yeah I don't see men
really want unless there was marriage or
something but wanting 50 50 I think
they're happy for the Saturday Sunday or
just Saturday I don't know I I think
most men want have I think most men want
their kids to turn out better and most
men want to be a part of that in general
um I I think sometimes maybe there are
cases where women kind of trap a man and
like the men are kind of resentful
because like they don't they didn't want
this kid to begin with and she kind of
knew what she was doing yeah would you
say that's true yeah
yeah no yeah I agree
um Okay so
do you guys think the woman is doing
the world of favor by having kids
[Laughter]
circumstances if she's
in a good relationship with someone then
then yeah it would be a good thing to
okay if she's single and just
yeah
most of the amazing world leaders we
have today wherever women so yeah I
would think so but yeah I say in general
yeah because women don't have kids then
because we often say that women are
special because we have children we do
not say I would say maybe they're more
during doing like a duty of nature or
what they're meant to do than a favor do
you think it's a duty it's planned by
Nature we're doing what we put on this
Earth to do kind of well I know it
doesn't sound the best but don't I don't
see it as a favor
it sounds like too much like a favor
it's like I'm I'm like created to do
that right so if the thing that makes
women special is having kids why do so
many women focus on their careers and
not becoming mothers you're talking
about the Modern Woman the Modern Woman
is not it's not a traditional woman so I
would think your question the first
question is truly take more to a
traditional woman so the modern woman
doesn't want to think traditionally but
they want traditional men it's funny
isn't it like yeah they're modeling but
they want traditional men they're very
focused on what what did you say with
the career if they're more focused on
their career then if the thing that yeah
the thing that makes women special is
having kids because we'll say things
we're like the givers of life right like
why do we like they'll say we won't run
the world why like yeah yeah that's
that's comp you'd agree that's like
common in the culture yeah right yeah
yeah
um so why do so many women focus on
their careers instead of becoming
mothers this is the thing I think
feminism can brainwash you and it
brainwashed me a bit at some point where
you just sit down and think wait this
doesn't add up you just pick and choose
and that's very true where you say they
say we're special because we make
children but then yeah they push Focus
Korean independent boss lady
um just delusion of feminism yeah I
agree
look at that
I think now also you can have kids later
on in life as well so females I didn't
realize that oh I can and like there's
more opportunities for women to go and
work it's easier life there's probably a
bit more single women like later on so
we're gonna go and yeah but I don't
think we really can in general like
we're fatter than ever
and even even in the UK they'll call
America fat because yeah yeah
we are we are but the stats are not much
better here I looked it up one show I'm
like what are they bragging about
like I mean they're beating us but I'll
buy much
that's like saying oh I got 45th Place
well yeah we're second in the world
right USA the first I don't I don't I
don't know where it is I just remember
looking it up and like thinking that you
guys were fatter than you really give
yourself credit
but but so so I'd imagine if we're less
healthy right we probably don't have as
much opportunity to get have children
and it's it costs the average person
twenty thousand dollars to do in vitro
or any of that stuff so the most women
aren't going to be able to do that yeah
who's got 20. and there's no guarantee
that'll even work yeah who's got 20K
lying around to play with anyone in here
no no
not laying but
so it's like it's almost like they
brainwash you with that too would you
agree or disagree
yes but I think also it's like women go
off to University and after University
they're not telling you go and have a
family they're telling you go and work
you spent four years and wrapped up all
this debt you're gonna go work right so
they're not thinking like oh let me go
find a husband now because maybe most
men maybe at that age don't want to
settle down and have kids so they're
like well what am I gonna do was that
what you were was that where you like
maybe followed as well like try to go
uni what they said and focus on Career
no well I was like go to UNI and leave
this country that's right I'm like as
soon as you that's what I did as soon as
I finished bye girls yeah why
why it's cool yeah so many reasons like
now I'm like oh my gosh I love this this
country but back then no it's cold it
rains all the time the cost of living is
high like it's people are just not but
then I feel felt like they're just not
nice like no one's friendly if if you
think it's not nice here come to Eastern
Europe
that is true
I remember
yeah so um I'm an athlete so we raced in
Latvia and it was in the indoor track
and I remember all I was doing was
walking from one part of the stadium to
the other because one of my guys was
racing and I remember I was walking and
then I saw this guy look at me and he
looked at me grabbed his girlfriend oh
instead and I'm just like I don't want
you again and he stared at me all the
way to the outside of the stadium
especially when you walk on the main
road like they stare at yeah a lot of
things
yeah I'm not gonna lie your Rarity I I
grew up in Lithuania first time I seen a
black person I was 18 and I was taking a
video from far
it's real like the first person
yeah yeah unicorn I recently went to
Lithuania uh went to Ebola and I was at
another girl I was chilling we were
having a drink and some guy walked over
to you it disgrace you know to the woman
she's between him so obviously maybe you
know I mean but it was funny like you
know it's a bit intoxicated but it was
that recently did you say yeah recently
like wow like last month July yeah yeah
yeah do they have internet
listen no one knows this our internet is
like I think number one in the world the
fastest light speed so Missouri
you know because I had
um Someone I used to work in I used to
work in that town and as a Polish girl
and she said that when she lived in
Poland the the image that black people
have in Poland was so bad that when she
came to England she was surprised she
was so nice she was like oh my gosh she
married a Jamaican man had kids it's
like in the Poland you are not seen the
same way no but women love you the the
Lithuanian Latvian women love black
people well it's just men but the white
women they they like you what is it
don't worry then uh Poland recently
during the Ukraine Russian war the
Africans away crossing the border were
getting sent back to where the bombs
were falling so they were you know so
even though the ukrainians coming to go
to Poland but African the blacks were
being pushed by so yeah my mum went
Poland with her polish friend she said
she loved it everybody people were
really nice
her friend's son was obsessive Bob
Marley my mom's got lost and he was like
he was very very what's the word
mesmerized yeah they changed now they
changed yeah yeah but the students in
Lithuania are saying when they called to
get like an apartment they don't get
away from oh um I'm from Nigeria okay no
no really it doesn't matter if you eat
it you literally have to have a little
girlfriend to even get a reference
but a lot of people are still really
nice like 90 you get nice experience
yeah it's opening up a bit but yeah
still back out there so I have I have
another question
why is it when a father abandons his
child they call it a deadbeat dad but
when a woman aborts her child they call
it a choice
yes
right um abortion and about well it's
probably one of the few times the ladies
who think I'm exciting for them I don't
think abortion and abandoned you know
the same thing okay why
um
it's not about you when the child is
born it's a fat person right so but like
a dead a guy that knows they have a
child he he has a child it's choosing
not to like
why would you want to abandon somebody
who you know would need you right but
could you say the same thing though yeah
both choices yeah but but but a woman
who's say for example six weeks pregnant
and she she thinks she's not ready
she could decide to about a child's not
born but when he's born he like when he
did the same thing like he could think
he's not ready
yeah but the child is here that's a name
that's the song one I mean yeah but
there's a unique DNA code with all of
the like but the child's not suffering
it's just like maybe gone the child
could be crying with the dad it's
someone's hell it'll affect them but
that doesn't mean that it's right that
she has the choice but there's a fit
person you know like you always say
um a woman shouldn't leave the marriage
because of cheating think about children
it's not about you anymore so I would
say when the child is born and that is
called deadbeat dad like it's not about
him anymore about the choice whether he
wants well couldn't you flip it and say
the same thing when like once you're
pregnant it's not about you anymore
you could but the human is not there yet
it's unfortunate that she can choose to
just get rid of it but at least the
child is not suffering but the child is
forming though yeah but it's not
suffering but how do you know that
there's not there's not like conclusive
evidence that says that it's not
suffering and even and even people that
are in that field disagree on that there
you go you're right if they still met if
there's no metric to measure that like
that we don't do you know of any metric
they can measure if someone is operating
the fetus no I'm just saying for example
if the child is born you can tell if the
child is sad happy or whatever but six
weeks old you can't measure anything you
know what I mean I mean they can let you
know what stage or what what's going on
but you can't measure anything so that's
why it's kind of like it is true yeah if
the woman wants to and the thing is this
right if she feels not ready it's
equally irresponsible to
um to to proceed with it they should be
able to have that choice
if you realize you realize you realize
that 90 of biologists say life begins at
conception so if you're gonna go with
the science like wouldn't you go with
the science
right okay yeah the life is there but no
one's crying so
if I kill a baby with euthanasia does it
not count I don't think it doesn't count
I'm saying it's the difference
if she now uses abortion as a formal
contraception so she does it regularly
then you can you know like like 40 of
women do yeah women that have had
abortions have had two or more but what
does it mean if it's not a child then it
shouldn't matter like who cares it's
just a form of control being a deadbeat
dad is with an abortion because you're
actually doing damage to a person that
will become part of society and it will
affect us all as a society but abortion
is just affecting that woman abortion is
killing the child yes but you can't say
it's just a woman though because you are
brought in the child
it's all hypothesis we know a deadbeat
is I hear you but you haven't taken no
consideration how he might feel a
viewable in a child I'm not saying it's
right it's it's it's completely not
right man there might be some people who
might be some men that go into mental
depression because they could have had a
child in this world that they wanted
abortion it's crazy though because I
think with the question you asked
previously about if men were given the
same Powers women to create life after
in men there will be more abortion if
men could do it yeah yeah because very
there'll be more abortion so women are
you know they even actually giving birth
quite a good rate no I disagree I think
it'd be a small percentage of men that
would want abortions I think you're
telling me one in three men can't
reproduce
and like the average like I don't know I
think a lot of average guys would want
them to have the kids
um you see I I I'm in between on that
because I I feel that
if men have the power to abort a baby
they probably will
but at the same time there might be a
lot more careful to ensure that doesn't
actually happen so it doesn't get
they'll be better people in society like
no no as in like they'll preventive
prevent the woman from actually getting
pregnant so
and I think as well right that abortion
should be changed to actual what it is
you're actually killing the baby so
let's say it for what it is because
you're actually terminating a life
once the sperm has fertilized the egg
that is the life this is a living
organism but that's the thing like we
try to change the language to take
accountability off of women it's like a
common thing because if we say follow
the science but then why don't we follow
the science when we say that 90 of
biologists say that it's life at
conception so why don't we use the terms
that they are but it's like we try to
play it down to take accountability off
of women do you think if woman's not
ready to have a child she should still
have it oh yeah I mean my mom got
pregnant when she was 17 but she she did
the right thing where she had it and
gave it up for adoption and then I think
it's incredibly selfish but they know a
lot of Statistics women already have a
child and the the drug abuse the alcohol
and then
but you can give it up for adoption
it's not easy it's not it's not it's not
easy it's an incredibly hard choice and
and it's incredibly hard I saw my mom I
saw my I saw I saw my mom go through it
but but the thing is like she she
understood that she made her bed lie in
it yeah and so if you Cho you can be
absent if it's a different situation
without getting pregnant for just a guy
what if it was completely
the woman was great
you know that's a difference
it's always but that's always like the
exception that women bring up when it's
only point zero one percent of of all
cases of abortions are great and so and
so it's like we bring up that exception
to make the rule but it's not the rule I
could say the same when you said your
Mom is pregnant at 17. Mom pregnant's
15. and I can't obviously disclose what
happened but she decided to keep my
brother honestly and
I feel like you think it took an
exception to keep it I don't I don't
think that she
I think she was far too young
you mentioned about giving the child for
adoption it's not every country or every
continent that has happened so it's
either you know you're moving the goal
post we're in the west all of my
conversations are about the world when
I'm bringing up abortion statistics like
this is about the worst okay exactly so
I'm saying but I'm saying no no no no
Flagship country right but I'm saying
we're in the west we're talking about
the West we're not going to move we're
not going to move the goal post to not
talk about the point I'm trying to make
is whatever decisions uh whatever laws
coming to the United States we we
generally think that it's just gonna
flow down right everything I don't
generally think that I just I'm not
gonna have a whole conversation about a
country that I don't I'm not there
so like I don't know about which country
like why would I like like I'll give you
you said Nigeria earlier why would I
have a conversation about Nigeria when
I've never been to Nigeria I have no
idea what the laws are about there I
just but women get pregnant in Nigeria
right I mean you could say yeah women
get pregnant everywhere but like we're
talking about the west and you can come
on my show and say let's talk about the
rest of the world but that's not how it
works like we're talking about the West
yeah I get you okay
um so I'm gonna Read Super chats for a
second I know we had some Wi-Fi issues
at the beginning of the show
um so we'll we'll see how these are
going thank you for for sticking with us
through these I know this move has been
kind of wild
um okay so lover 41 hero to all rip Rod
Robin Williams and the judge said all
said all the money but he shortened it
to alimony the man had a lifetime of
alimony debt over half a million for
26 I didn't know that for 26 years
oh my gosh that's crazy alimony not even
child support
um
handyman101 the birth rate is not at
replacement levels in the west want your
Society to die Empower women let them
vote no vote more babies lover 41 hero
to all Robin Williams got married more
than once so it's no wondering why he
worked so hard till he he roped and his
body didn't fight back Doug MPA Pearl
explained to these women what
missandries mean these women are just
assuming that men don't want their kids
and it's blatant Miss Andreas stop it
John the Baptist why is it that so many
chill children childlike adults male and
females fighting to be less responsible
lover 41 hero to all remember if
remember if Einstein couldn't keep a
woman Will Smith Magic Mike Channing
Tatum Johnny dot Michael Borden or Chris
Brown or Chris Brown what chance I got
oh wait there's two more
um Al Pearl your new name is the top
Sheen now the top G is gone keep in line
the dumb deaf and the blind sentient do
you think if a woman is not ready for a
child she should have it as an adult you
don't know that it you don't know that
if you open your legs that you could
possibly get pregnant how about you just
not sleep with anyone who you don't want
a child with accountability
um okay I think that's all of them I
even want to speak their piece any
comments I like that last one the if you
if you don't want to have a child with
someone just don't sleep with them like
at the end of the day we all know even
protection nothing the only thing that's
100 is abstinence so if you do then you
can't be mad at the other person if you
do have if you end up pregnant like
because you knew it was a risk well
another thing is like we only get
pregnant like four days in the month
you're up so it's like
and and we have 41 forms of birth
control you couldn't try one like we
have so many options to not get pregnant
you can get an IUD of a 99 point
something percent chance enough would
you not say a lot of young women get
pregnant because we're not really taught
I didn't know to to get on anything you
know I don't know if a lot of women went
for the hair or talk from a young age
[Music]
I mean I just think I think 10 and 11.
so did you have a choice you could have
go to doctor and get the pill just like
that with your mom may feel concerned I
just I think that's just a lack of
accountability I'm sorry if you're if
you're born in the age of the internet
you don't have an excuse no like you you
can Google what like what happened I'm
sorry you can't tell me any 15 14 year
old doesn't know that if you have sex
you can get no you know but but you just
don't care and you make that choice
anyway that's that's your own fault I
feel like when parents don't talk about
sex and and anything school is not
enough you might feel shy asking your
parents and infants who might risk I
mean I I disagree I did 12 Years of
Catholic school I I grew up in like and
we had no teen pregnancies in my high
school
except maybe they're actually there
might have been one but she was kind of
not I don't know if she was telling that
there may there may be was one but like
no no confirmed
um was it a girl school or girls no it
was girls and guys it was like a mix
yeah but I just I just I think that a
lack of of knowledge is just an excuse
like I don't know how you can get to be
14 15 and not know if you have sex you
you get pregnant yeah you know but but
you just don't care
you're not Macho enough to fully
understand the risk you know what could
happen but I just feel like you know so
if someone if someone's 14 15 and they
shoot somebody yeah you don't think they
know what's gonna happen they know but
they don't I just feel like they're not
mature at that stage someone needs to be
more in control of them too much media
for that they they definitely notice
yeah
I think they know that maybe not
thinking about the long run in their
future but you still know whether you
decide to think about your future or not
whatever you're doing at a young age you
still know what can happen what the
consequences will be I feel like that's
too much too heavy to put on a 14 year
old yeah you know I mean yeah there's a
reason why if you were to mess with the
14 year old go to jail because they
really can't make that sort of the state
kids
but I understand with parents they
should you know from I don't know like
you said your your parents uh you got to
have a conception from 12 or 13 or so
yeah that's why they should you know do
that but just pack the 14 year old to
you know you have to expect to say Mom
let's go to doctor I want contraception
it's it's a lot
I mean it's an uncomfortable
conversation but but the parents should
say okay you know maybe we should get
you something maybe before we even
happened
on hormones at 13 4 15. I would just you
know start the conversation but you
should know your child when they might
be having all you know they're going
parties you just you as a parent I feel
like it's more of a responsibility for
you than a 14 year old to say Mom let's
get me contraception I'm doing it you
know what's interesting the more
contraception
um like
the more they put sex ed in schools like
the more people have sex so the more you
talk about kids with sex like like
before they started putting that in
schools like there's a large proportion
of high school students that graduated
as virgins yeah don't agree talking a
lot and so even that point about and she
said about
um parents giving contraception the
legal age isn't even 14.50 so you
shouldn't be having sex anyway yeah I'm
gonna go to their parents because they
know that they shouldn't because it's
not illegal and also I was going to say
is that especially when it comes to
um learning about contraception and I've
got a conversation for my parents I
think it depends on your job
so you have people you can actually talk
to again this is a very media driven
right now so you can plan something on
the Internet yeah which depends on like
I said your household
actually I was close to my mom I'm close
to my mom yeah yeah so there's not a lot
of people like that so yeah your case is
cool there's a lot of people that yeah
especially at the age of 14 15 you
shouldn't be having a age because it's
illegal
yeah so you're really gonna go to your
parents and say oh I'm having sex at
this age oh so I suppose if you're a boy
it might be a bit more it might not be
as bad as if it was a female saying I'm
having sex with a guy yeah at that age
but at the same time it's the same as
smoking a cigarette you're never gonna
go to a parent say that so I think with
sex none of us will go to our parents
and say is this safe enough even if I'm
17 it's I think smoking's a bit
different
or drinking alcohol well it's illegal I
think it's a bit different because
there's the what can come from it
is the impact of drinking the alcohol at
14 and smoking a cigarette is different
from having sex and getting pregnant but
parents it's very taboo like sex parents
treat sex like if it was illegal like
cigarette you can't come even if you're
17 talk to them I think it depends
Generations some parents also you've got
some parents that might not be able to
relay the information to their child so
they understand it because think about
if you for example if you had your first
child at 14 15. you may not be able to
relay that message to your child
effectively because you might not learn
something
so some people may not be able to go to
their child and say
XYZ so I'm saying yeah I have a question
do you guys think that a parent should
let their kid transition from like a boy
to a girl or girl to a boy at 14 15 16.
no no no no
I'll say no and the reason the reason
why I'll say no is because I think
um
trust me but um
I I think that's
um
APK is still developing at that age and
talking to your kid about transitioning
basically
changing from one sex to the other
is a huge thing you know
um so many things will happen and I
think the parent needs to let the child
to really get to understand their body
for what it is and then later on in life
they can then decide if if they want to
then they can then decide to do that but
I think at a very age encouraging a
child to basically
change things yeah so does everyone
generally say no did anyone yeah so
generally yeah I'll let my child know
they should do that when you're an adult
okay okay anyone no no yes is in here
okay so why do we let girls go on birth
control which changes their body from a
young age like 15 16. and can and you
can have your hormones can be changed
forever and never go back is that with
every form of pet control
um even even copper it has negative
effects on your uterus so you are
effectively changing their body what's
the hormonal change yeah like for
example it changes who you're attracted
to a lot of girls will go on birth
control and develop like different
conditions with their hormones where
they can't regulate them effectively
after like five ten years makes you gain
a lot of weight go ahead well you said
life is about Traders right so would you
if you don't go the contraceptions would
you want to take the race the best
changes your body a lot yeah
I understand that I understand that but
the point is that you're putting a kid
on it
they're fifth 14 15 16 years
14 15 year old yeah right but that's
that's what I'm saying it's like it's
very common for girls to get on birth
control at 15 16 that's not uncommon and
that that's the safe age to get on birth
control I'm not a fan of birth control
like I I yeah I don't like really I
wouldn't put my kid on birth control
whatever any form whatsoever no I think
as well though
um birth control like the effects of
birth control aren't really publicized I
didn't even know them well I didn't know
that it had hormonal changes in in women
I actually didn't know that so no you
did it no
wow so I think it's not
I might be the only one yeah
but I don't think it's well for me I
don't think it was publicized enough
to really know that it had such an
effect
on women
so it does
but that's non-hormonal what's the big
like
are you talking about yeah like copper
coil
um I've just heard that's bad for you
I'm not I'm not going to pretend I'm
like a scientist on here and I know the
ins and outs of every birth control my
only point was that it changes their
body possibly forever and you as a
parent are helping them make that
decision so why is one allowed I feel
like I rather risk that than getting uh
pregnant early is that is that changing
from a young age or
an old age what do you mean the the
marina the hormone does it change more
when you're younger or yeah
um
I don't know what that I'm saying is
that the film The Copper no the copper
one and I think it's done wonders for me
the I've heard that's like better than
the other ones yeah it's non-home and
then they say that but they say they say
it's bad for like if you want to have
kids later yeah
it's harder for you but I think you know
I think there's a lot of stigma in birth
control it's like the um the injection
is a form of birth control and a lot of
my friends have been on it and they've
come off of it and it has made me fat
it's made me this I'm depressed I was on
it the baby will make you more fat
because there's a lot of women that have
get pregnant and go right back to the I
think is this
yeah no they used to I think like women
are just fat today yeah which is nice
which women like which most women like
to be fat rather than slim now do you
think they like I don't think they like
you yeah we like the big thick fires
they like they like okay a big butt with
a small waist that's not fair yeah you
can't have a big lots of small way to
evolve surgery but this one here she's
got a great shape she's she's got big
butts small waist naturally is is it
depends on your state yeah and I think
you wouldn't see it's just
but I mean most women like to be
bigger now nowadays rather than deemed
skinny maybe they pretend they're happy
because there's body positivity I'm
happy big girl's life is being as big as
Lisa or yeah
she happy okay let me ask you let me let
me she's making money what do you rank
lizzo one to ten ten uh no based on
money
okay okay
look one more time I'm so confident
she's so confident do you really think
she's cries on Instagram live oh I don't
know that much about hers no I see her
and she said are you going do you
genuinely okay do you genuinely think
she's happy at like 300 pounds how could
one be happy does she not look happy I
think she looks different TV I don't
know her personally so I but from what I
can see
looks wise
Associated
okay okay so so one to ten you would
trade trade your body with hers
gotcha
okay
let me let me just let me finish this
like why do you lie no no let me let me
finish let me finish you said she had a
good figure yeah dude she would be
offended if you said she looks like
lizzo would you be offended if I said
you look fat
[Music]
no I think if she wanted to she'd do it
she had those she was on Tick Tock like
on the treadmill I don't have Tick Tock
I don't you see a whole different side
of words
what's your metric because she's
confident with it
anybody that's confident I think yeah
women race with feeling not logic yes it
comes with with how you feel that's what
I can see I was big and I'd liked it but
it's a big small what made you like it
because I was different and I couldn't I
don't go gym I I hate gym I hate
anything healthy I eat everything not
healthy but I liked it then I like it
now I and I'm very confident but do you
know do you not think there's Universal
standards of beauty so when everyone
walks into the room where everyone can
kind of okay when everyone walks into
the room you don't think everyone has a
general perception of who's more
beautiful and less beautiful
I don't know these days no I'm not I'm
not talking about these days I mean in
general well yeah and okay even even
take us in the room you don't think most
of us like they could say who's more
beautiful and less beautiful and I'm not
trying to put us against each other I'm
not saying to be rated but like I'm
saying like you don't think in general
you know who the pretty friend in your
friend group is I think what she's doing
she's thinking of uh like you say always
women's perspective so if a man is a bit
ugly but he has a lot of confidence in
the woman's eye he becomes more so
that's how women view other women okay
because she confident is more attractive
but men don't look at women like that
they just because she confident she
doesn't become more attractive actually
we see her wait you see her
how many points does confidence give a
woman
three three points of fives
one yeah
don't you like a shy girl though I don't
mind a shotgun man like shy girls no
okay lizzo so what would you rank Liza
one to ten zero okay what is she what is
she with confidence
still zero okay why yeah I assume yeah
because I feel like for me I don't
really think you have to be very good
looking or whatever but I think whatever
you've been given naturally should make
the best of that that's what she's doing
no she's she's she got fat
she wasn't bad
you think okay do you think women are
naturally fat no but do you think okay
so when he says do the best with what
you have naturally he's talking about
like being in shape and like you can't
change your face
but you you can get on the you know on
the treadmill but she maybe she doesn't
want to maybe she's happy I I don't
think maybe it could be or maybe she's
lazy I think she's lazy
on treadmill on Instagram but she she
just doesn't have the yeah you know
things like overactive fire rules
underactive fight you can okay I'm sorry
go into a poverty-stricken country where
are the overactive thyroids
like now she just likes to eat a lot and
she's lazy like especially with her she
has no she's being lazy when she's a
performer just look at it no excuse me
maybe she's not lazy but she just eats
too much so no matter how active you are
if you eat more calories than you ban
you're fat so maybe she just yeah it's
like a form of lack of discipline and
self-control which is lazy you should
probably perform and then just eat ice
cream afterwards
the only reason she's striving is
because we're living in a walk Society
where you're trying to encourage women
to be you know plus size be you know be
confident whatever if for example if
tomorrow she stopped getting gigs and
say Society doesn't like big women
anymore you'll see her slim down I've
got a question for you if you had a
daughter and she was little size
how would you feel about it
you take her to the doctor
wow
family and friends who are that big I do
have family and friends and saying what
I said we do you wouldn't be concerned
with her oh wait if you had a daughter
you wouldn't try to like feed her last
maybe exactly as a parent you can't be
like oh if that was your daughter it's
then it's your fault yeah it's different
as a child
[Music]
yeah I don't know because because of my
parents doesn't mean I don't go to bed
so maybe when I'm I'm in bed they're
busy eating everything up so then lots
of cupboards
that doesn't matter because at some
point you would see the hurt increase
so you will notice that holding a second
why are you getting so big so quickly
how many how many how many big women in
your family like just say just do you
know any big women in your family like
lizzo there must be at least one
two I know you said to them look I'm
concerned about your weight you need to
go doctor you think they'll listen to me
yeah but that's they're not his kids
though this is different kids
but what we're saying is they got big
they got like that based on their life
choices
one of my family members actually lost a
lot of weight
a lot of weight
so there would have been some form of
encouragement stimulus into a into her
brain that said you know what this ain't
right for me and I have another family
member that actually wanted to do the
same but like pearly said oh also once
discipline wasn't there like nobody's
actually happy fat nobody they're always
trying to lose weight she's just
accepted it I even I even might not be
happy I even know guys that'll say like
oh I would date bigger girls like I find
them attractive
but but they're so insecure it's a
headache who sorry I've had guys like I
I talked to people women all the time I
do this like four times a week so I'm
always like the in and out and I've had
guys say like I find bigger girls
attract probably not lizard side they
probably just mean like you know
but but they said they won't date them
because they are so insecure and they're
always like talking about their bot and
it's just annoying to them
well that's different then that's
because they're that's just they're
insecure well I'm saying like I don't
think fat people are actually confident
I just think they say that to themselves
to make themselves feel better but
they're not actually confident you feel
like the same way of skinny people that
are really stuck cannot put on weight as
quick as they can with the fast
metallics I don't think it's the same
I'm sure yeah I don't think it's the
same so if you saw a skinny person you
said oh you look skinny today I think
most I think
a good amount of I won't say most but I
think there's a portion of guys that
don't that like if she's in shape it's
fine like I've had guys say I've asked
guys like would you prefer a BBL or just
a girl with no butt and they say no butt
really yeah yeah who wants a BBL that's
fake right that's not like yeah
I'm sure I'm sure the preference is like
you know the the goods or whatever yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah but like like I mean
I'm just saying like I
I I think there's a difference between
someone who's skinny with no butt and no
boobs and someone that's 300 pounds is
big I mean
she's just accepted she's fat and that's
the that's what that's the mindset we
need to change it's like you shouldn't
accept that you're fat you know do
something about it do you know I think
it's the media as well that are telling
this this is what I'm saying
she's getting put on Vogue or whatever I
don't know but you know they basically
celebrating her for me like that so yeah
putting fat chicks on model cut like I
missed the models that used to make me
feel slightly bad about myself that's
they're supposed to do they're supposed
to be the epitome of beauty that's why
they changed it yeah but I don't know
what that's too extreme there's like two
extremes either really skinny or really
obese with the average people I'm not
saying like really skinny I'm saying
really beautiful they were quite thin
back in the days you know why because
they're not really that beautiful in
real life yeah they've been very
airbrushed yeah I don't know so now
they're trying to lower it to more like
actual Beauty I don't know I've seen
like the Victoria's Secret Fashion Show
those girls are beautiful like I can't
you can't tell me that you can't tell me
Kendall Jenner isn't beautiful she's
skinny really skinny she's pretty in her
face what about plus size models like I
support them proper plus size like 12 14
maybe 16. 12. wait 12 UK
is 14.
sorry I'm from Lithuania Maybe
then you can get away with it but when
you just basically bust them out of your
clothes you know it's see exactly that's
the thing like whatever size you are
accommodate your body you can be even
lizard side no and still dress for your
body you can she doesn't have to come
out if she likes to come out in crop
tops and just show everything you don't
have to what about the hell your health
but some people are it might be
relatively good health not at 300 pounds
yeah definitely not no maybe not her
size but bigger people can still be in
relatively like good health you can be
real real thin and have bad Health yeah
but people just associate oh you're thin
you're healthy yeah you're big you're
unhealthy unhealthy but actually it's
not like that well I think in general
the thinner people tend to be healthier
and the fatter people tend to be not but
if you're too thin you're really not
yeah but come on come on okay okay what
percent of girls are really too thin
nowadays
I was from there were
yeah but here in the west yeah no people
aren't that thin anymore yeah I think I
don't think that being too skinny is a
problem and here at the UI
yeah in general some but in general not
really
not really
um okay I'm gonna take a second to read
super chats one more time
um guys thank you for the super chats
this really helps us get new updates for
the studio we want to get two more
cameras in here
um I also would like to get a logo
behind me and um blessing wants a new
chair so we'll see we'll see
um okay also subscribe to the channel
you already know if you've watched two
or more of my lives and you don't
subscribe we have beef so make sure you
subscribe to the channel so
um old monkey bones do you think that In
the Heat of the passion that men would
take a more logical approach to birth
control if it became their
responsibility
um that's actually a good question we'll
start with that when we come back
um Bank the batuci lizzo's built like a
generous scoop of mashed potatoes
um Nathan the bay man study at the
Charlotte lazier Institute showed that a
12 week old unburned baby feels in
response to pain increased heartbeat and
moving away from need tools slogan free
fed out with a hundred dollar Super Chat
let's go
um Pearl I follow you and agree with
what you say about Western women I'm
done I have a condo in the Dominican
Republic uh in the Dominican Republic
and a rotation in South America but
Western men are weak I'm 60 feet healthy
and I see Western men as weak Cowboy
crypto as a child speaking about sexual
orientation prior to the point of
hitting puberty would it be considered
by a pediatric psychologist to be
presented presenting signs of
molestation and some actual abuse
um
Sheldon Ross Pearl I love your show
don't talk about the trans BS because
they'll come for you even harder and I
don't want to see you getting super
super canceled Matt butcher I know they
are young but it still amazes me the
hordes of people are so how deep they
form their opinions without searching
for facts find the truth look at what
others do not what they say Al big man
less our arm workouts and more squats
than legs looking like pencils
um Doug MPA guy in the lot in the green
on the left and the guy in the glasses
next to him are stamps pearls calling
out the UK simps every single show thank
you Pearl keep it up Al Pearl your new
name is the top sheet now that the top G
is gone keep enlightening the dumb the
deaf and the blind Let me refresh it
really quick before just to make sure
make sure you guys like the video that's
the most important metric that YouTube
uses to push out these streams there's
over a thousand of you in here right now
so let's get to a thousand likes we're
at 470 right now that is the most
important metric that YouTube uses
um okay I'm gonna actually take this
question I think it's a good one do you
think that In the Heat of passion that
men would take a more logical approach
to birth control if it became their
responsibility no this is what I was
saying before that men were not logical
in that moment no I do not believe that
men us their thinking logically okay at
all I I I disagree I think men go are
you invested are you on anything but you
want anything but okay but remember we
spoke before about like oh women have
more power and like you know your body
and blah blah are men really gonna be
like are you ovulating right now like
when like is this no but they don't say
that they definitely say oh you want
anything are you taking it but not
necessarily means they're gonna you know
but even if you say no are they gonna be
like oh no oh yeah it's true yeah so
that really like they may act like
they're being logical but yeah they're
just
are they really if we ask you and you
say no
what more can we do yeah
don't do it don't do it that wasn't what
she asked you she said In the Heat of
passion if your man had couldn't if a
man why are you asking if the outcome is
the same you're still gonna do her
what's the point of us well you could
offer after a pill right
what are they what about what about the
guys what do you guys think I've been
thinking about it um
you're the flashback
I think if if you're in the Heat of the
Moment
and you know I was responsible
are you responsible oh would I be
responsible like
sorry what was the question
okay do you think do you think In the
Heat of passion that men would take a
more logical approach to birth control
if it became their responsibility
yeah so going back to it I think In the
Heat of the Moment
I think most men
would slip
slip yeah as in like most men would not
um take accountability because
you know how it is you know
um
how is it yeah can you explain
I think In the Heat of the Moment I
think you would just want to like keep
going you know
um
if you then had to take responsibility I
think stopping at that point in time
would be difficult
I'm just
I guess I'm just talking for myself here
but
um
what if what if if it was like a male
birth control
do you think more men would be
responsible I think if there was I I
personally if I had to take it I would
take it because I know the implications
of if I didn't take it and the lady was
to get pregnant
you know and I have to pay child support
and do all these other things um I think
I would be extremely responsible because
[Music]
um
um there's so much at risk which I don't
really want to have to maybe provide for
someone that I'm not really
um it depends on the relationship you
know if you're in a long-term committed
relationship then that's different but
if you're in a if it isn't a
relationship like that then I think uh
yeah I wouldn't take any risk but then I
find even if it's they're not in the
relationship men still take that they
don't take that precaution
so whether the contraceptions there or
not men are still doing the same
craziness a lot of men don't I think I
personally would okay yeah I personally
would okay what do you think yeah with a
question about In the Heat of the heat
of fashion so
crazy I've just throw the spanner into
the whole thing
um
I'd probably go where he said like a lot
of men would uh lose it
um you know knowing in that moment and
saying oh no I'm not back control
they're probably just oh just lay slide
and stuff so yeah I think
um yeah yeah love me with Lego and what
what about birth control you think if
men had to take birth control would they
be more responsible oh yeah yeah yeah
okay absolutely like they'll take it
every more if you have to take every
twice a day they will be on that stuff
because it gives you that more sort of
like an added protection right yeah
because maybe women don't do that much
because abortion is available what if
you had abortion available would you
still be on it or you're like I got
plumpy
wait
because that's the only option the you
know the pill no I would still be on it
I wouldn't want to go through a process
where I have to take out a baby like oh
my baby so I'll stay Beyond it
like 100 I'll be on it like crazy
because maybe a lot of women they don't
take ritually because there's there's so
many options after pill abortion but
again I'm
I'm answering these questions based on
the fact that I do not know how pet
control affect women so I don't know
you'll I can only hear from you you know
what I mean I just see as a former
conception or a tablet you can take but
I don't know how it affects your
hormones and stuff so based on that I
don't know I'm just saying based on what
I know I'll just take it all the time
but then if it makes me crazy every now
and again I might not so yeah
what do you guys think
uh the first positions
I think men would take more of a logical
approach
um
because I'm thinking about it just take
me for example if
firstly if I am doing a bareback it
would be someone that I could see myself
um having a kid with if not then I
naturally would strap up now if I was
made aware so me personally I'll be I'll
first find out before I even have sex
with a person if they're on anything
that's me I can't feel for everyone in
the heat in the moment huh In the Heat
of the Moment I would because if I know
you once you say it
let's look at this yeah
it's I've so me personally it's either
I'm going to put the strap on First and
she might be like oh no it's fine
sorry
sorry
no but this is me I naturally put a
condom on
straight away I don't think twice but
I've been told a couple of times I
didn't need to because they were on
something so I'm saying well or if I
wasn't going to I'm first going to ask
if I need to right now I reckon there's
a lot of men that would ask
been awesome and I wouldn't ask
but I I still feel like if the
so in regards to I still feel like if
that was the case and you are because
even the case of I remember someone's
saying about if
you asking and she said she isn't and
you're gonna ejaculate anyway I don't
feel like you're going to get to that
stage before you even ask you more
likely will ask beforehand because if
you if there is a risk you can get
pregnant you're not really going to want
to ejaculate inside anyway so I'm saying
so that's why I feel like in
and also
um this is one of the terms we hear a
lot in um media about digmatized for
example there's there are some men that
if you're really good at it you can even
change the way the woman's thinking
you can change the way the woman's in
Canada so
in that respect
yeah I just feel like for that first in
that initiative I feel like as men maybe
not all men my father has men if
we could
make a logical decision at that moment
we I feel like we would make a lot of
men would make sure but there are some
men that could also you think
celebration there's a lot of people that
drink and talk that have sex intoxicated
so your brain even thinking right so I'm
saying if you're both intoxicated then
you probably won't have that question
because
it is what it is in it but then it's
both decisions then yeah and in regards
to if would men take birth control I
think we would because then it more
likely eliminates that risk there so you
ain't got to worry about oh if I do
close you're gonna get pregnant because
you know she won't so you have to as men
you'd have more freedom yeah you'll be
like okay cool I know my birth control
she ain't gonna get pregnant I ain't
gonna worry about that's gonna make sure
no diseases and I ain't got none I'm
saying so I recommend would take it
because it eliminates us from having to
be told take accountability be
responsible yeah we did we have control
don't come to me no more so I'm saying
so
that's my point on that I'm thinking um
if men was taking birth control it'd
probably be
more men more Reckless because yeah
you're not gonna have my baby anyway so
like
but obviously it's a dangerous game
um and in terms of you saying
um
will men be more responsible if
I forgot what you said
would men be more responsible if uh
logical approach
do you think In the Heat of the passion
that men would take a more logical
approach to birth control if it became
their responsibility and yeah I think we
would take more responsible I just think
because we don't really think too
emotional
um along the lines when it comes down to
having
having sex and if we know we're going to
get something out of it
um knowing that yeah she might she's
going to get pregnant then men will
probably put their foot down and be a
bit more serious about the situation
um
if that if the rules were reversed I
would assume I'm curious from the man
what percent from your personal
experience and your friends experiences
um what percent of women require men to
wear condoms well percentage Yeah what
percentage
[Laughter]
many people told me they didn't even
need to ask and I've I've actually had a
friend that said that they just the
girls get in yeah
so it's like yeah um but then to be fair
there's a lot more women on birth
control
compared to before on it so that might
be another percentage why I stole do you
want a specific number like yeah like
would you say 10 20 50 80 maybe around
40. 20 25 maybe 25
only 25 like ask
put it on just what about diseases
I feel because
women are mostly kind of majority might
be chasing that top top guy in it so
they might not even care
um
yeah so yeah it would be a small it'd be
a small amount of women
because not yeah they they choose who
they are Did anyone say over 50 percent
so women why do you
why do you think women in general so
reckless with their sexual health
I didn't know that
because this is actually High numbers
most shows I've I've gotten lower when
I've asked this question I would say the
average I've heard from guys was like 10
to 20 like 40 That's the highest
percentage I've gotten my one of my best
well my best friend is a is a male and
he went
um not in Hill Carnival
he said
one thing that stood out to me said he
went around the corner of a girl
beautiful girl showed me a picture of a
beautiful girl went around the corner
had a quickie oh wow no in the carnival
in the carnival no uh contraception
nothing they just did it did it and then
left and obviously okay yeah she got his
number he's got his number and
everything vice versa whatever but
if it's like that in carnival God knows
what more sorry
where like where did they go behind
someone's house there's many places
there's many places many corners there's
footage of people doing all sorts and
everyone just thinks they're dancing
it's a form of dance you know it's a
form of dance yeah
I went to do the interviews but like
there's people everywhere they don't
care they don't care there's loads of
food have you not research at the moment
there's a little Carnival like I just I
wouldn't touch it I went to my first one
to do interviews but I was I didn't see
you've seen it you wouldn't see it
because it's quick
I would be scarred for life
sometimes the best way to hide something
is to do it in the open I don't know
yeah
[Laughter]
and then they just get videos like put
on like Twitter or something
yeah well stuff wait does that is
Carnival like crazy here yes it is you
haven't seen anything you need to go
back
I saw the crazy outfits but I didn't
realize that we're just like did you put
it in the crowd okay I'll tell you what
happened so hi I've heard okay I've
heard a lot about Carnival and everyone
I've never been to a festival before so
this was like an interesting like first
one to go to and
um so when I went I did the interviews
and I always asked like what on Earth
would you do for eight hours straight
like I just in my brain like it doesn't
compute like what are you and everyone
says just Vibes what does that even mean
like I don't understand what like vibing
like like is that you just chilling
I think I'm just like mentally an old
person I don't know
and um so the last hour I was like okay
I'm gonna try The Vibes
so I was like I told my cameraman I was
like you can go home you know oh yeah so
because it was like there's like an hour
left in carnival so I was like I didn't
I was it was horrible
like one I got in this like I wanted to
leave like at the end and I got in this
crowd and there's people everywhere and
then people try to grab you I'm like no
yeah well guys not trying to touch you
up and yeah they work yes
and you can't even run away because
you're just like yeah but I was just
trying to leave and it was like then I
ended up by this like parade thingy and
oh my gosh it was it was a lot but that
was only an hour so I can't even imagine
how people do
like a full but I think the girls they
complain they just bend over start
twitching right when they get grabbed
that's why guys touch you up because
they think you're gonna
think strangers yeah and I was so
confused I'm like do people know each
other it's very weird like black people
why do you do that is a culture thing is
why people would never do that there was
this video in a Daily Mail where this
girl was twerking on the policeman yeah
and a guy was grinding on the police
woman as well like I'm saying what's
going on if you understand the Caribbean
originally policeman if you understand
the Caribbean you understand that it's
it may not look but it's actually
harmless done yeah that's how we move in
the area so more time more times are not
when you come to Carnival you come with
a mindset that that's going to happen
but there's a lot of things
it harmless if the dude like took the
girl behind the if you're telling me
people having sex everywhere
no no no no no no I'm talking about the
Vibes inside that big day
but no minutes normally go to Carnival
is that for example if you go to certain
places in the Caribbean listen to their
music and dance with it it's a lot of
it's a lot of provocative dancing but if
you have that mindset that you're gonna
you're gonna go there some people want
to dance with you that's normally what
yeah tends to happen but there's some
there's some people that go overboard we
can we can admit that but doesn't it all
end up in sex if it's not this moment
The Exchange number it'll be later it's
a lot of sexual attention not always
true or at least always right at least
an election
erection well if the girl is attractive
and she makes you exactly yeah let's
dance right by the end of the day not
every not every man from there thinks
okay I'm gonna have sex with you that's
a good question okay since it's harmless
are you guys cool dancing with like a 60
year old lady a six-year-old lady yeah
because it's harmless it's not sexual
yeah
to be honest with you or a lizzo sized
lady no no no no
no no no no no no no the old and one but
the thing is your grandma
when you talk about lizzo and when you
talk about a six-year-old woman that has
nothing to do with the action that's to
do with my me wanting to dance with her
so I'm saying so when we say harmless
I'm talking about if it's harmless are
you gonna let your grandma
remember harmless
no but you need to remember what
harmless means it means what is it
without harm so I can dance with lizzo
and a six-year-old and she doesn't get
hurt at all that's harmless wanting to
dance
to it though that's what we're trying to
ask in some cases there is in some cases
in all of the cases it's sexual why
would you exactly exactly that's the
point that's the point when you said
when you said harmless like I was just
interpreting that as like it's not
sexual so I understand like most of
dancing no one's getting hurt yeah like
mostly but the reason why I say that is
because there's a lot of cultures
outside of the Caribbean that wouldn't
dance that way so when they see you
starts that way there really is a
negative connotation to it yeah but if
you are part of our culture you
understand what that means okay maybe
the harmless wasn't the right word yeah
but a lot of the so the way how we dance
it may not lead to anything sexual after
that it may be just that dance are you
wife so are you cool with like wife and
a girl that goes to Carnival every year
and does the full two days
it's harmful it's harmless it's not
sexual
if I'm there
no no no this is just what she's been
doing the harmless harmless last last
couple years before she met you
don't change it don't change it you're
not there this is before she met you
yeah so you were you didn't know her
she's been going to Carnival she tells
you yeah I've been here for five years
Vibes personally I would okay because if
she's Caribbean like me I would okay but
she's not Caribbean does it change it it
depends on how well she understands the
Caribbean culture and Carnival okay only
because because like because because I
because I am Jamaican I understand that
that form of dancing so maybe harmless
may not be the right word to to have
used yeah but I have done so me
personally I've danced with many girls
in that way and once we finish we went
our separate ways right so I'm saying
you go to your with your girl to the
carnival if you're okay for a guy to
dance no it's harmless
if you're not single you should know not
to dance with anyone else right it
depends on something I think when he was
saying that it's harmless it's like it
doesn't look to anything right it
doesn't always if you can dance like
that with your friends yeah that's what
I think is harmless like it always leads
to something slowly
it doesn't leave the same day
guys guys one at a time please yeah so
she just said it leads to something it
always leaves something slowly I
disagree because I dance with friends
and it's never lit to anything yeah [ __ ]
it doesn't always lead to sex but the
sexual in the tone is what we're talking
about there's some there's something
going on if someone if a girl's bum is
Right grinder against we're growing if
there's something going on right okay
okay I just wish I could pull a video
right now I'm just girls twerking at
carnival and you're telling me there's
no sexual understanding the dance alone
is sexual is
why did you not get hard if it's not
sexual why are you getting hard please
not always but half of the time half of
the time that's because that's because
there's someone you're attracted to but
if you're dancing with someone you're
not attracted to you're not gonna get
well you wouldn't dance with someone
you're not attracted to that's what you
said yeah I might go to the thing I
might dance with a friend a guy friend
female friend yeah you're excited a
female friendly do you think men and
women can just be friends
yes yes
I've always said that in most cases a
man and woman can be friends if the man
isn't attracted to the woman no and then
your friend yes accidentally male
friends didn't yeah my girl her
girlfriends that's okay oh it's true you
know the difficulty with it is
wait
when
I would hope my influence would make a
choose the right friends to be with
based on how they can impact our
relationship but I don't think that's my
final Choice do you not think if if a
man said to her let like if she said I
want to have sex with you all the male
friends will say yeah let's do it that's
yeah that was an experiment yeah but I
don't know what you're going with that
yeah there was an experiment on YouTube
right this guy stopped couples in the
street and says okay
does he does a girlfriend have a male
friend yeah yeah whatever yeah so okay
we'll do it we'll run an experiment get
the girl
call your main phone right now yeah I've
heard of that and say I want to happen
so you have since you have male friends
would you call one on the show no and
see if you did have sex exactly no
because do you think they'll say yes is
it is it Primal in a man to just be like
oh yeah but that's that's what I'm
saying like they wouldn't be friends if
they wouldn't be friends with you if you
if you were 350 pounds they're friends
with you because you're attractive
are that excited to hear us talk but
there are men that like 350 pound women
there's a couple but that's usually
because they can't get the hot chicks
and you see that because okay Jesse
Williams she's Jesse Williams you don't
know who Jesse was grazing out okay how
many times why do we hear the term
trophy wife because it's like a wife
that's a trophy and she's good looking
yeah but they're boring yeah why do you
just assume that because you could just
tell that's probably why they melt like
who give me example of a choice if
someone like them
um Cristiano Christian Melania Melania
does she look like she's in love with
Trump you can have he's got all power in
the world that's a trophy I mean that's
a trophy wife with the shoe look like
she's smart too she knows three
languages oh that's great yeah she's no
she's smart I'm saying like you can't
just assume just because they're pretty
they're boring she looks like to me
that's like a mating strategy
I'm not a trophy wife who looks really
happy as a question Cristiano Ronaldo's
like who's the one that they that he
picked her up off of a shoe store was
that Cristiano Ronaldo's wife yeah I
don't know yeah I think there's a lot of
trophy wives that are very happy because
I almost think they're happier because
they understand their roles but do you
see there was a media showing us do you
think that's what the media showing that
they're happy
um I I don't know celebrity
relationships are always a weird so I so
I don't know but I'm saying like I I
think when you're in a relationship
where the man and the woman understand
their roles they tend to be happier
when it's a trophy wife like usually I
mean like a girl that stays home and
raises the kids and then do you think
the man's probably feel oh that's my
wife she's got her role she's got her
payroll she's I'm doing this do you
think that he's gone out and had
something more fun because that's his
wife I don't know well probably no I
mean men that make more money like get
the option to cheat more so more of them
do sure but I think women cheat more
than men do you think his wife is
cheating now
I I think it depends I think it depends
but I don't know what your point is like
all all couples have problems just
because she's hot doesn't mean that she
offers she's let like she's boring I
think that's a mating strategy women use
to like like to make them less
competitive does it say that the hot
girl is boring or she doesn't have any
brains or whatever no no I'm not saying
she's not I'm not saying she's silly I'm
just old yeah I'm just saying that she
just I don't know what she looks like
because it's bad yeah but obviously you
know what Christiana looks like I don't
know his wife yeah I didn't have a clue
yeah is she really pretty is she
um I I don't think she's stupid pretty I
don't know I think I don't know I don't
know I've just heard they have a very
like cute relationship I don't really
know because he doesn't need you back to
what we're saying if you if you let your
girl have male friends then
um it's not you might trust her but you
know they could they could disrespect
you whenever you don't have to say but
the reason why I can't just say no is
because they can be there might be a man
in her life that has been so invested in
her life from a young age that she that
he might have a part to play in her
maybe mental sanity for example so for
example my last girlfriend
she lost both she lost both her parents
her boyfriend was like her Rock
they broke up I can't tell you why they
broke about on the other hand but he was
so instrumental in her keeping her
sanity I can't just now say you can't
speak to him you don't need to be
without don't be with her that's just
smart Away by the way I'm the neural
wait I'm the new yeah wait wait can I
wait but there's a part of her life I
just want to understand yeah so so
because she was like there for her
before you allowed her to be friends
with her ex and you continued to date
her
yes but the reason why that's crazy
you're a feather so
I was only with her for a short period
of time what I'm saying is that there
was a part of her life I don't know
about uh-huh yeah I don't I didn't know
what she went through but he did so you
want her to be with a dude that knows
more about her life than you no it's not
even let them be together it's not even
that though it's not even that it's a
situation where until I was I didn't I
didn't get enough because I wasn't with
her for a long amount of time I didn't
find out about all the history because I
didn't find out about all the history I
wasn't able to replace him
are you friends with some of your exes
too me yes no I don't I don't I don't do
you have a lot of girl is there friends
I've only ever had one girlfriend no no
friends girls are friends not really
female actress so the only girl you
picked today was the girl that was
friends with her ex
actly I I get why you allowed it but I'm
just saying it won't run with me like
which is which is perfectly fine but
what I'm not gonna do is just
automatically say okay cool because I
know how men are automatically
you can't talk to any man because I
don't know because I don't because I I
didn't know her past and I did and I
didn't give myself enough time to find
out about her past so I'm saying and she
went through a lot of stuff in the past
maybe it was a short things yeah I was
only with her for like nine months right
so because I wasn't for a long amount of
time I didn't know all that history to
then say okay cool I can now take it why
did you two break up can I ask for the
reason I'm curious so the reason why we
broke up was because
so she said she liked me but I never at
that moment felt the same way but she
was the first person to ever say oh I
like you so it made me feel a kind of
way so I thought and I would I wasn't
really
I wasn't really taught a lot about this
growing up so I kind of had to learn for
myself right so I thought okay cool she
said she likes me I think she's pretty
maybe I can grow into this these times
I'm going to University so I was going
to University I was working and I'm an
athlete as well so I really had no free
time and what happens is the level of
commitment and attention and the seeing
I couldn't offer it
you you went that into her that's why
you allowed I think the universe
conspired to save you man that that
would trust me probably got saved
probably but but because it was the
first person to ever say that I was like
okay cool I actually got excited because
me as a man I don't really get told any
kind of things so I thought it sucks I
thought maybe I can grow into it and the
more I'm in that relationship the more
I'm realizing I'm not really on you like
that that's what I'm saying so I so I I
broke you off because I said I can't
give you what I feel you need so it's
better you find it from someone else
they need to be half hide and did she
did she talk to her ex like the whole
time you were together no no all the
time not all like but like like when you
guys broke up was she still in contact
with him I stopped chatting to us I
don't know you don't know like a month
before like if she was still talking to
him
maybe maybe I think we can assume based
on the importance he's had in her life
then they probably were talking so maybe
yeah have any of you had girls that were
taught into the access when you just met
them or
um
not I know like if if I'm gonna take it
serious then those are the questions I
need to ask
and if I say yes then
just a smash and pass I guess
what about you
no no what about you no
[Music]
um
so this is kind of going back to the
original topic we get a little bit off
and we went to Carnival
[Laughter]
[Music]
um okay why would you say that
Father's Day doesn't get as much
appreciation as Mother's Day does
in the media
this is a mad one some women use
Father's Day for themselves again they
celebrate
nobody cares about men really that's
okay
I think it's simply just because the
women gave birth so that's the biggest
thing ninety percent of women are the
the main parent for the child so only
ten percent raise on themselves the kids
why but then there's the percentage that
are in two parent households which is
like the other half right true
men don't really get the appreciation
that they deserve
and that's I think partly the reason
would you not say women spend more time
raising kids usually so that's why
naturally and you know man's working
he's still helping really much but
raising kids women I mean he has to
provide and that takes a lot of time and
it goes towards it still goes just he
has to go to work and get it
sorry you could say because he's hardly
there because he's providing yeah so
he's hardly he's hardly seen but he's
he's behind the scene doing what he
needs to do so but there are adverts
just there's there's advertisements for
Father's day as well but what I'd also
say they just don't really get it's just
yeah it's not crazy it's not the same
like how Mother's Day is
but then they say that women are more um
they're more into buying in mental so
there's a lot of um yeah advertisements
from what women because you're more
likely to buy advice
just a side note to that is when it
comes to Mother's Days men tend to put
more effort into making sure the mom has
a special day but when it comes to the
Father's Day I don't think that energy
reciprocates how about this does in
Lithuania we celebrate it's a big
celebration women's day no one
celebrates hair
I don't know if you've seen it but it's
a women's day you know what's
interesting there's International
women's day it's big in my country
there's even there's violence against
women but there's no violence against it
and there's no Men's Day yes yes and in
Lithuania everyone policemen give women
flowers it's very big and if you don't
bring flowers it's like and what do the
men get on Wednesday There's No men's
day that's the thing it doesn't even
exist
so why why do our women
why do women think that one of the
reasons we're special is because we give
birth but dogs do it
and we don't think dogs are special oh
[Laughter]
maybe it's harder to raise a child than
a puppy
I suppose I can say but then the women
wouldn't be special because men were his
kids too no because look at what we you
know we're living in capitalism Society
look at everything the high-rise
buildings the trains and everything will
mostly built by men and who were giving
birth to by women so I would think they
hold some form of power to be able to
have given birth to men that created all
of this yeah so talks unless he had a
dog that built a bridge so
what's what's harder to give birth or
raise a child
so then by that logic wouldn't women not
be special
yes well
I think kids are special a man or woman
is just women are still special because
they are all most most of the time they
involve in raising up the child so they
give birth they also involve and raise
another child so yeah
but sorry man
that's all I guess it's just because men
can't give birth that's the only yeah
it shouldn't be like but that's but
isn't it interesting like we we put
women on such a pedestal for giving
birth but it's like dogs do it but then
it's only the female dogs
so maybe we should put the female dogs
we don't yeah it's like but I think
maybe like going back to before why
Mother's Day is so like more publicized
and celebrated yeah
there's so much more money to make from
buying females gifts like you can buy
them flowers we don't we don't get guys
flowers you know so it's like oh I think
everything that basically in society is
all about how can we make the most money
we can make the most money yeah so of
course Mother's Day is going to be
bigger why do you think that is like why
are why do we buy gifts for women more
than men
do you think maybe there's just more
things that you can I guess buy you can
get him a PS5
not more smaller things you know like
you can buy a woman like a pair of
tennis shoes Jordan like but then maybe
it's only limited to like shoes games
watch ties suits like
I don't know do men really feel like if
we get flowers
like if we get you like some nice
earrings are you gonna be as happy or if
we take you out to dinner are you gonna
be like females I think it's apparently
due to female that's it because you guys
just love to take as much games as
possible but I I was gonna say something
I think it's this might be an
interesting question to ask if next time
you're out in the streets if men could
get it if men were given the choice to
get pregnant and go through the process
how many men would take it
so if we had a choice if you could go
press the button and you get pregnant
and go through the whole process nine
months and give birth how many how many
men would want to go through their
experience there you go so that's you
that's why women especially so they go
through it is
no I'm just saying you know like you
said yeah well just because red don't
want to do it I still don't think that
makes women special just because like I
could ask I could do the same thing in
the street if you could get if you could
have a child without giving birth like
it's complicated didn't it it's
complicated did that same question and a
lot of the women said no if I didn't
have to give birth out I could just have
the kid I would right no one really like
I think that's awesome
so but like the point is like we we hold
that on such high regard but like right
we all agreed raising a child's harder
and yet we still put women on this
pedestal remember because there's a lot
of risk given birth and there's a risk
not anymore used to historically there's
risk in giving birth now you're you're
not you're not scared of death when you
go
like I've never heard of a man die of
fear during childbirth women die during
childbirth right yeah but it's not just
it's not the norm anymore well I guess
it used to be the risk is always there
the risk is always there right but it
doesn't like to me and then if 50 of
women are hitting 30 and like they're
predicting that 50 of women between 25
and 45 will be single and childless in
the future like does that make the women
that don't have kids not special
um
yeah would you say dollar special
the childless women
but maybe your ability to give birth
makes you special if we don't use it
then it may do it or not it's like you
could do uh that's what's make you
special from the men
that's what makes you different from the
men that you so because you're different
you're special do you not think yeah
yeah I would agree with unique
definitely yeah unique because it's
through us that you know
reproduction I don't know if if Superman
could fly but he never flew that was he
special yeah I think if they don't give
birth then you just he no he would be
special regardless if he flew up because
he's the only person who could fly and
you're like you don't even know if he
can actually fly
she may not even be able to have kids
you don't know I mean what about the
women that are barren
[Music]
then maybe just women are special
I don't know I don't know
you think so
when you were here
I don't think women are special at all I
feel like we're I feel like we're told
we're special from a young age but we're
not we knew what is unique for me
how are you unique if you're 50 of the
population but I mean what your your
abilities what you're able to do by what
you've been told to do by Nature yeah
makes you unique yeah but then half half
of women can do it it doesn't make you
that unique but I'm just saying women in
general well like I'm talking about a
particular word like one woman I said
women in general if they're able to for
the father able to they're able to bring
life that's that's unique do you think
if they invent artificial wombs
and no it is and no longer need women to
reproduce
and why would a man need a woman
you can start getting you know
breeding serial killers you need that
child mother nurturing too you know you
can't take that away yeah but you could
hire a nanny
so
what to breastfeed the child
to take care of the child you could do
formula I'm just saying like that's what
they're saying nowadays like what what
does a man get from a woman that is what
he get from an artificial womb
companionship
I know I think a man and a woman needs
each other if you go you know like woman
doesn't need a man or man artificial
womb they'll we'll see we'll see the you
know the bad signs of it yeah what do
you think will happen if that actually
happens you think men will use it I
think like you say more women will be
tomboys and more logical but they'll be
less
femininity and less softness in the
world I don't yeah I think we'll use
that
I think I think the one out of three men
that are virgins or haven't had sex in
the last year I think they will
I feel if you've got no other option
like I do have a question for you Paul
why do you think that's the case why why
did one of three men that's not hot sex
um why I think it's because women are
hypergamous and even historically only
40 percent of men reproduced so I think
that's just like normal so basically
you're saying the guys I know getting
sex I don't know just because they're
able to afford it
um I wouldn't say afford it I would say
I would say there's there's more there's
yeah there's more than one attraction
cue yeah so I mean and there's like I
think like 40 of men are overweight I'm
sure that's part of it there's a lot of
men that just awkward out yeah and I
think
deal with women I guess as well
yeah and then like we're getting into a
less socialized world you know it's so
it's like there's more people that have
lost social skills women are more
hypergamous than ever we also have birth
control
so I think birth control I actually
think birth control started everything
because after birth control it gave
women the option to sleep with whoever
they wanted and not have to deal with
the consequence so you could go for a
guy that's more and more out of your
league and being you don't have to worry
as much if he'll stay or marry you or
before like women had to kind of like
Get on their level because you had to
pick a guy that was going to stick
around and who's gonna stick around
someone that's on your level yeah I feel
like you know like guys are not having
sex that are not having sex with women
can actually change that
um you can change the you can reshuffle
your cards right you can you know try to
improve yourself forget about sex you
know improve yourself go to the gym try
to you know become high value and the
woman will come it's like they just want
to sit at home play Playstation it's
just it's crazy so you already know the
personal percentage of people that play
computer
that's just uh yeah nowadays yeah but
I'm just saying like to to not to want
to expect it when you know the game is
set against you what you should be doing
is to reshuffle the cast you've been
dealt but I wouldn't say
men just expect to have sex it's just
something they just don't have that
capability to have sex
well I think I think in the old days
like men were told to get a job be
stable and like like you don't even like
get a house get a job and like women
will want you but like
you know men can do that and still not
get a woman because they're like don't
have cloud or don't have certain
symptoms and I think there's nothing you
can do about the cards you're dealt in
life so the best thing you can do is
just you're right like focus on yourself
like go to the gym make more money like
do all the things that women like but
like some guys do that they still care
that might not change but improve your
chances right yeah I agree with you
possible yeah I mean because what else
are you going to do we can either sit at
home and not do anything yeah exactly
um I'm going to take a second and read
super chats and then I think we're going
to close out the show
um thank you guys for coming round of
applause for the channel
um okay
super chats real quick black is Panther
any man that would not Trace places with
his woman and child per birth if he
could not does not deserve a woman a
man's job is to protect his woman from
Pain and Trauma if he can help it the
men in the panel sound like modern men
smooth deep International Men's Day
exist it's the 19th of November November
but no one cares about it Joseph Metzler
children raised by only one parent have
a different outcomes depending on
whether it was by the father or the
mother a child raised by a father has a
higher percentage chance of success Pew
research Eddie why Father's Day isn't
celebrated because fathers don't
complain they're busy working thanks
black panther
um KCF Zack the girl in the sweater
doesn't believe Ronaldo Ronaldo's wife
is happy in spite of the media but
believes lizzo is happy because of the
media Clifford range they're dancing
around questions like a sombrero Alistar
Horton is it meant to be a dancer a
mating ritual Casey fsac read the case
against sexual Revolution by Louise
Perry shoe little myth Firestone a
radical feminist had a severe mental
illness at 67 starved to death and her
body was undiscovered for days Sheldon
Ross guys are lying it ain't hard to get
girls pregnant condoms are almost 100
effective cheap and protect from STDs
they still don't use them Cowboys crypto
birth controls the removal of
accountability at an individual level
and you are attempting to argue that it
improves individual responsibility to do
so what happens in the one percent
chance that it fails Benjamin watching
for a few weeks no weeks now thank you
for Pearl for being thank you for being
the pearl of wisdom in the sea of modern
mentality fifth fan keep up the good
conversations take a high keep up the
good work Pearl and team old monkey boss
oh that was the same question
um okay guys so now we're going to go
around any final thoughts anything you
want to just speak your piece on go
ahead you can do that now so starting
with you and then go around
yeah
oh no final thoughts okay
um final thoughts
um it was interesting discussion
um I I used to look at men and women
everything has to be 50 50 I think I had
the influence from friends but I am more
towards like women and men are very
different in our roles are very
different and
with that accountability I just feel
like both should be very very
accountable and don't put the decision
in the strangest stranger's hands where
you know they're meant to protect it and
yeah just protect yourself
yeah I agree I think
women should be the ones that should
really think about
the situation when it occurs
um I have more for men on that side I'm
not a feminist at all I argue with them
all the time but um
I think just just again be careful on
both sides but more 70 30 on men for me
yeah first of all shout out to Pearl for
providing the platform to be able to do
this
um like I said I've told you earlier on
I've watched you from 1K subscribers and
yeah check out the Briny video very good
one I love the hard work you put in so
well done
um yeah interesting conversation today
um very good to hear different
perspectives and then different opinions
about this whole thing I think the
conversation should continue with you
know men and women
um I just the more we talk the more we
find that common ground right so
um so yeah things like this sort of uh
it's a catalyst for that also check my
uh YouTube uh Camille news
um we we review videos as well like
Pearl which is the only started doing
that recently so yeah we got Brittany
Arena check it out it's going crazy
has she I was actually thinking she's
Wilding what have you seen with Mr I
don't know why they're giving out so
much nation in America you need to
review that with Mr letgo we're getting
we haven't set up the reaction area here
yet but we will right so yeah yeah
over there
I'm sorry go ahead
um yeah it's been a fantastic discussion
um yeah thoroughly enjoyed it
um I had a thought actually
um has anyone seen that video online
about
is in America this this lady the the guy
sort of brings McDonald's
yeah we reviewed that one too yeah yeah
go watch it Camille knows she just came
to me right now and I'll say oh is that
the one yeah we reviewed that as well
the McDonald's baby mama pay for all my
children yeah yeah and and I was just
thinking it's so relevant to this
discussion you know about how obviously
like when we're talking about you know
some you know women like bringing up
their kids and stuff versus the men so
um yeah I just thought yeah it's a
brilliant discussion I think and we
should continue it and um yeah it's been
great
um yeah no final thoughts
um enjoy the
the discussion in the panel uh thanks
for having me Paul yeah and
that's about it yeah I think
yeah so thanks for having me
um it's good to hear different
viewpoints whether you agree or disagree
at least you're able to
formulate whatever you feel you need to
say without no favorite backlash to a
detrimental effect so
yeah thanks again
um final thoughts
um I still think that it's 50 50
responsibility I do agree that women
have more power on the outcome but at
the end of the day I don't think that
you should be sleeping with anyone you
don't intend to spend the rest of your
life even have children so
okay I'm gonna read the last couple of
super chats thank you guys for coming
round one more round of applause
um okay so a couple super chats left
um lover for one hero for all sorry for
the delay response currently at work 16
hours for the last two to three years so
I decided to join the chat username is
lover on hero to all hacks GP question
for the men if your wife wanted an
abortion of your child because she
wasn't ready what would you do
um yeah that's it we're closing uh black
is Panther okay okay then we're done
okay guys
um don't forget to like the video on
your way out that is the number one
metric that YouTube uses to push these
streams across YouTube so make sure that
you like it also go follow our Clips
channels we have Pearl daily and just
pearly Clips we have two different
editors run the accounts you get a
couple different like editing Styles so
that's why we have multiple accounts
um we have a new membership tier which
means you get a one-on-one session with
me once a month you can use this you
know for you know personal problems or
or some people are on YouTube they want
to like you know get better at it so I
can do that
um that's once a month um just dot
pearly things
um on Instagram
follow that I'm almost to 50K I'm also
almost a 350k let's go
on YouTube so make sure you subscribe if
you've watched two or more of my laughs
and you don't subscribe we have beef
make sure you turn on your notifications
so you know when we're live like the
video on your way out and we will talk
to you next time